[Music]
of the many children of queen america
there are a set of twins who have been
born as omens
morgoth the grace given and moog the
lord of blood
in order to understand these two we must
first know what omens are
but this is actually quite hard to
answer as we don't really have any solid
information of this
but there are speculations
so what do we know about omens
omens are accursed beings born with
horns growing throughout their body
and they harbor cursed blood they also
seem to be born at a certain degree of
randomness
they can be born from commoners where
their horns are cut out from birth and
they are unlikely to survive the process
but if they are born from nobility their
horns are left alone but they are
shunned away forever to the sewers of
lane dell to hide them as a defect
if you go down the sewers
you will still see several omen there
though their chains have already been
broken they still stay within this
decrepit sewer for many reasons
and despite the harsh treatment that
they get all the women want is nothing
more than to be loved
there is an item made to memorialize
these babies and within its description
is a plead for mercy it reads please
don't hate me or curse me please
now while being an omen seems to bring a
depressing isolated and cursed life
there is a tarnished who wants nothing
more than to be an omen himself and to
spread the blessing of the omen to
everyone
he is known as the loathsome dung-eater
this
uh sane tarnished wanted to become an
omen and wants to spread the blessing of
the omen and to do so he murders people
and defiles them with a curse before
they die as such when they are reborn
they turn into omens
the first omens could have been the
souls of those defiled by the dung eater
and the harsh treatment that the omen
receive could be to prevent this curse
from spreading
if true
then even the god's children are not
immune to this curse
that said despite being forsaken and
cursed the omen are a hearty species and
are able to grow they grow to the size
of ogres and are fearsome in battle
despite their grotesque forms they are
fast and powerful
they are even gifted weapons for war
for when the time comes that they must
serve they will serve
even the two omen demigods with their
golden lineage would not keep them from
the treatment of an omen as such they
were kept within the sewers of lane dell
under the strictest of confinement
they could not leave for they were
shackled through magic
but eventually
during the events of the shattering
they would find their way out and pursue
their own path
now the first of the two omen twins
we're going to talk about is morgot the
grace given
he is the current and final king of lane
dell
at the dawn of the shattering queen
marika vanished into the earth tree and
her children waged war at each other
the seat of the capital was an important
position during the war
and many would attempt to besiege lane
dell but with the seat of the king empty
the defenders might not last
morgot would emerge from the sewers of
lane dell and fight with the defenders
to protect the earth tree
after which he would ascend to the
throne not to claim power nor to rule
over the lands between
but to preserve the throne of his mother
protect the earth tree
and the golden order
morgot would seal his cursed blood
within his sword and would even seal the
sword within a cane to ensure that his
cursed blood would never stain the
throne of the earth tree
morgot would invade no other demigod
save for one who committed the sin of
blasphemy
for morgoth still believed in the rule
of his mother queen america
once the shattering had begun
landed would come under siege by one who
carries the hawk crest and the defenders
would fight with all their might
and there would be talk and legends of
an omen who would slay countless
champions and he would come to be known
as margat the fel omen
he would be a horror to those who harbor
ambitions for the earth tree
in truth though margaret and morgan are
one in the same there are many
speculations on why morgot had to hide
his identity
but the prevailing theory is that he did
not want his omin self to be associated
with the royal family so as to not sully
their name
once godric's forces have been beaten a
second attack would come to lane dell
an attack so revile
that morgoth would not stand for this
sin
the sin of blasphemy
the attack would be hard fought and this
would be the turning point for the
defenders the forces of landel could not
sit idly by while this sin existed
within the lands between for the sin of
blasphemy was an affront to all that is
gold
with the capital secure the forces of
lane dell would head towards mount
gelner towards the volcano manor
their trek to the volcano would be as
perilous and dangerous as one would
imagine
and sir gideon ofner would call this the
most appalling battle in the shattering
the volcano mount
lies in the west of the altus plateau
the realm of the earth tree it was the
stage of the most appalling battle in
the entirety of the shattering
reichard has committed the grave sin of
blasphemy
marking himself as an enemy never to be
forgiven
we can still see remnants of the battle
and to this day many soldiers are still
fighting with no hope of victory in
sight
there is also the case of the frenzied
flame within this area but that'll be
for another video as a new tarnish that
arrived in the lands between
margaret will be the first wall that
blocks you towards your path to claiming
a great rune
marget is aware of the weak and cowardly
godric
and he would block the path of those who
would attempt to slay him not out of
compassion for godric was the perfect
bait for tarnished who harbored the
flames of ambition
and he sought to nip them in the bud
before they grew you however are a
tarnished of great skill
and though margaret would escape
we would eventually head to the capital
of lane del
where we would face him once more
outside the capital as he tries to stop
us once again
and finally at the throne of the earth
tree we face morgot
the last of all kings as the tarnish
destined to be elden lord he is no match
for us
[Music]
and if we take a closer look at margot's
body as he lays dying
it seems his omen has been cleansed his
body no longer showing horn or tail
but how this came to be i'm not too sure
however
things don't go as planned and morgoth
despite being the true king of lane dell
would be rejected by the earth tree
and it is revealed that all are rejected
from an audience with the queen
though morgot saw himself as a failure
his great rune is the anchor that houses
the base of the elden ring
and is proof that the omen king
was born of the golden lineage and he
was indeed the true lord of lane dell
he is probably one who loved his family
more than any other of the demigods
now let us speak of the second of the
twins the luminary mog and the lord of
blood
mog was the opposite of morgot he
resented how he was treated and came to
hate the order and the greater will
during the shattering he escaped from
the sewers of lane dell and came upon a
revelation
an outer god known as the formless
mother
a being a mother of truth
this mother bestows power upon a cursed
blood
and she craves wounds
and when mog stood before her in the
deep underground his blood erupted into
flames
he would then understand that the curse
he was born into was not a curse
but a gift of love
he fell in love with the defilement of
his blood with the curse that brought
him hate
because of this he would set his new
palace within the underground but even
after leaving the sewers of lane dell he
still protects the chamber deep within
he protects the path towards the
frenzied flame probably a measure put in
place to keep those who seek the
frenzied flame out
but i can't say for sure if this is
actually him or simply an illusion that
is similar to ronnie's spell with
renault or like god phrase spirit in the
capital of lane dell what's for sure
though
moog protects the final hidden passage
towards the frenzied flame
now we could talk about the great
dynasty he is attempting to build
but in truth his dynasty was doomed from
the start
and it may be nothing more than the
ravings of a lunatic
for his dynasty is filled with nothing
but promise of fake power
his great rune is an accursed rune it is
similar to morgoth's rune but he filled
it with the cursed blood the followers
outside his capital are nothing but
husks used to give up their blood for
the luminaries demands
his only true followers are the sanguine
nobles who revere him as they intend to
claim a noble rank within his dynasty
should it come to pass
even the white masks such as vary were
simply abducted and coerced into service
by promising them false power
his dynasty seemed so devoid of
followers that they would seek to
recruit tarnished from beyond the lands
between
but they also ensure that the delusions
of the two fingers do not encroach
and only those deemed worthy by vary are
to be recruited
aha
your intuition serves you well
my doubts had been piling up you see
the words of the two fingers cannot be
trusted
truly naught but rambling senile
delusions
i believe
that when the elden ring was shattered
the two fingers were corrupted their
guidance
skewed
even worse
the fingers
harbor no love for our kind
that's the part that irks the most
oh i have a gift for you something fit
only for the wise
a means for circumventing the draw of
the two fingers
give it a try won't you and if it please
you
may we meet again
i have high hopes for you
my lampkin
vary acts as a guiding hand for you in
the start of the game
to build your trust and eventually he
enables you to slay other tarnish
then once you've proven yourself
he recruits you to join the dynasty as a
knight of moog
upon your rival though
you will find that the dynasty has no
other knights
you seek violence
heedless of my warning though
raised into a knight of the
dynasty i am pained
to the very depths of my being
i'll ensure you regret this
my lampkin
reject
your miserable
death ultimately all that was promised
to you and to vary was false power
oh
luminary moog
please grant
the strength you promised
i
have given
everything
please
my lord
please
answer me
luminary
mug
[Music]
bless the moguin dynasty
with love
although the maguin dynasty seemed
devoid of champions it may not be the
fault of moog himself but rather the
formless mother for while the formless
mother grants power to those of a cursed
blood
its power also turns them into
bloodthirsty invaders and the bloody
fingers that may have invaded you are
able to do so thanks to the power of the
formless mother
the cursed blood can be gifted or cursed
to another such is the case with okina
and elenora
their weapons are stained with the
cursed blood
driving them forever to invade others
as such the champions of moog are much
too busy attempting to sate their
bloodlust
a true testament of mog's lunacy is when
he stole mykola the unalloyed
while mikala was infused with the
hailing tree
moog would cut out mikala from the tree
and bring his cocoon onto his palace
here he ordered his followers to render
their blood to the cocoon of mikala
drench the walls with blood
feed the cocoon blood for he believed
that michela's awakening would herald
the dawn of his new dynasty
however
no matter how much blood he gave mikala
would never wake from his slumber
mogu would spend most of his time here
building his dynasty a well-kept secret
even from the thousand ears of sir
gideon they all knowing
strangely enough when the tarnished
arrived we found a lot of albinourics
here but to be honest i think they're
not here to worship mog but rather
they're here because mikhail is here
mog's obsession with love between the
formless mother and quite possibly
nicholas ability of infatuation drive
mog's actions
he attempts to raise mykola to godhood
and in service of the formless mother
all for the sake of their love
godfrey has shown affection for morgot
upon his return
but both omens seek nothing more than
the affection of a mother
be that from queen marika or the
formless mother
who knows how different their life could
have been if they weren't cast out from
birth
perhaps these are the souls the lotesome
dung eater wishes to save with the
disgusting blessing he seeks to spread
for if everyone was an omen
no one will be